(content sigh) Oh hey!
I- Uh, I didn't like punishing myself over and over for these milestones.
So this time I thought I'd just, you know, relax.
Why do I need to punish myself anyway?
This is supposed to be a celebration!
And a 'thank you' to you guys.
So I came up with 101 ways to tell you how much I appreciate you guys.
#1 you guys have been with me since the beginning.
#2 you guys have been so appreciative of everything that I do.
*Ominous music*
Uh, 82: I know kung-fu all of a sudden, it's very bizarre.
I have no idea how that happened I just, uh....
*Music intensifies*
We know what you have done, we're coming to finish you off, *Creepy voice* we know.......
Uh, eighty three.. (music heightens, blocking out Mark)
*Splashing sounds*
(sounds of children creepily laughing)
Darkiplier: *Laughing* One...
(muffled sounds of protest)
Darkiplier: Sealed for your protection.
(muffled whining)
(heavy breathing)
(happy music plays)
(music fades out)